yeah because i know a lot of people they
cannot take like they kind of cannot
chew on like cold things or like really
cool things yeah yeah
at all i can't yeah can you not no i
[ __ ] i i love it too much where if
like i start chewing on ice yeah i
always hear you like you'll be talking
to someone you're like
just looking it's gone i'm not good it's
gone it's gone god's not even looking at
you just staring off to the distance
like doing crunching
i love crunching on ice
it's the best texture i love it i don't
know why i just it's
it's not good for my teeth at all i've
been told by my dentist and pretty much
everyone around me to like not do that
but like there will be times where i'm
like i i literally have to like
consciously not put ices in my drinks
now because i do it so much that
everyone's advised me to not do it is
that the real reason why you don't put
ice in your beer
i don't wanna chill on this ice man [ __ ]
the beer have you been in a social
situation or you're like drinking your
drink and then you're like all right i'm
gonna i'm gonna
take this ice i'm gonna put it in my
mouth yeah but the cube's a little too
big
and your mouth's really cold but it's in
your mouth right and it's in there it's
in one of your cheeks maybe your thing
is freezing
you have that moment where you're like
if i i'm you're talking to someone you
don't look like a weirdo you're like
yeah if i bite into this it's gonna look
weird but if i swallow this i might
choke and look weird so what do i do i
need to reply in 10 seconds and they
stop speaking do i spit the ice back in
the drink and look like a [ __ ] weirdo
because if i if i go
so you were safe
have you been in that situation yeah
many times and i'm like i'm like my
go-to option is normally like just pray
that you can swallow this without dying
just pray really yeah my my option is to
just start crunching on that [ __ ]
i mean the least weird one yeah that is
the least weird one i've never had an
issue because i'm like constantly
crunchy
i can't crunch it i'm always definitely
worried that they're just gonna think
i'm a [ __ ] weirdo when i spit it back
in but yeah yeah because if you spin it
back in they'll be like what the [ __ ]
yeah spitting it yeah spitting it back
in this is the worst but my teeth can't
bite into it but i also don't want to be
that guy who's like yeah
so i've
here we go this might be it i might be
dead how many ice cubes have you
swallowed in your life like uncountable
uncountable over 10.
yeah that's a lot like normally i would
just try and like come to your pb with
kind of
kind of try and move it around to get it
to a swallowable size all right right
melt it as fast as you can or maybe just
get it so that it doesn't have harsh
edges
wait you've swallowed ice cubes with
hard edges yeah like where they're like
full cue no [ __ ] way no [ __ ] way
yeah i i would not i would be so
terrified normally the technique but the
problem is that this is where the
technique fails is that i'm normally
doing this after i've drank it so now i
can't use water to assist it flowing
when i swallow right so i have to
swallow a dry ice cube yeah i was saying
that like like you just like take a swig
of water or something that will like you
know that would like help melt it a bit
i just swallow it and uh yeah one time i
think i had a really big scare one time
because it got stuck
but i remember i had to play it cool
yeah because i was like i don't want to
make them do a heimlich maneuver on me
so i would just kind of keep like
keep trying to swallow it before i take
a breath and then eventually it went
down and oh my god my esophagus was in
so much [ __ ] pain yeah and by the way
never risk your life for a bit of social
uh awkwardness just i should have just
spat it out but yeah it was it was
terrifying just chewing it like a i
could feel it because it was so big i
could feel it going down and then
getting stuck a little bit sometimes
yeah and then waiting and then obviously
it was because obviously my body's
really warm yeah so it would slowly like
dissolve you just gave your esophagus
like freeze burn what's [ __ ] hurt it
hurt
so much oh no [ __ ]
don't do that
uh the lengths that a british person
will go to not be awkward in the social
circle just spit it out at that point
just
just spit it out you know what if i i
was playing like the most important game
you know you know i will say
if i didn't love chewing on ice so much
i would probably do the same thing
i would rather
potentially risk having a choking uh
incident as opposed to having 10 seconds
of social awkward interaction yeah
that's right really yeah yeah that's the
british in me we just can't we can't do
it i don't know man like just like yeah
it's gonna be like yeah it's gonna be
[ __ ] weird you know like speeding
your eyes
or whatever but like it's like i don't
know how many situations can you think
of where you've say been to dinner with
some other person right what's the first
date right first date with someone yeah
first day for example right if you're on
the first day with someone right how
many times have you gone to a restaurant
with say another a lady right and she's
gone
anyway yeah and then that at that point
your head's like
no
wait wait i thought it would probably be
like
when is winning spitting ice back into
your glass the game changer i'm not
gonna lie it's one of probably the least
attractive things you can do it looks
very unattractive don't you think so
someone should
i think so
no no no no i think something that's
less attractive is you choking on an
iceberg
no on a date
that's a good that's a good show okay no
i wouldn't
i've
i've i've actually been in this
situation before actually not like
and i haven't swallowed it i've just i
just remembered
my chest is like
no it's it's it's the tissue technique
right it's the tissue technique no no no
it's not for a big ice cube they're
going to see your tissue on the table
you don't put it back on the table you
go for the tissue you pretend you're
just wiping your mouth or whatever
you're just like just
you've got to be subtle about it
you're
because now they're going to think oh
this guy just choked out a massive
loogie in front of me this is this ice
cream listen this this ice cube what are
you doing when you when you like exude
and exude when you take out an ice cube
out of your mouth you don't
no no no god this was this was like a
maybe a what how big of the ice keyboard
we saw this is like a four four
centimeter cubed a four
four by four by four by four centimeters
let's say let's say that's a big [ __ ]
ice cube dude yeah that's what i'm
talking about okay okay no no if it's
that size i never take the risk of like
putting it in my mouth yeah i'm not
putting in my mouth i was dumb i don't
know why
because like at that point right at that
point um you probably would have hardly
even drank your drink right because
i'm the speed
it's like gone like it's let's say it's
a banging cocktail yeah like it's an
absolute winner yeah i love the cocktail
so much or maybe you know uh i i'm like
i'm going to order a bunch more i want
to try some more so i drink it all and
the ice cubes are still fully formed
because like at that point like the ice
cube just doesn't feel nice like like
like if you can feel the edges on the
ice cube
it doesn't
when you swallow ice cubes i thought you
were talking about like you know when
you buy like a drink like mcdonald's or
something
are you swallowing whiskey rocks no no
it was like a i mean i come and watched
what i was like you're literally
swallowing like whiskey like it was like
a full-on formed ice cube like it was a
nice ice cube that's why i wanted to put
it in my mouth
because
i was i i remember i was like yeah
i was like i could get this down
you know thinking i was fancy probably i
don't know what i remember the exact
scenario i remember this specific
scenario the reason why i was so
committed to potentially dying to avoid
social awkwardness it was because
uh it was a first date and i was very
nervous and she was very attractive yeah
i really wanted this to go well and so
you were like i'm gonna eat this ice
cream
and so for some reason
i think the 19 year old like was tapping
into like the fit 15 12 year old to me
that was like that ice cube looks really
good
because you know sometimes you see an
ice cube and you just put it in your
mouth because you're because you're dumb
when you're a kid and you you want to of
course i
it really depends okay it really depends
as someone who has eaten a lot of
[ __ ] ice cubes in my life
as as the ice cube connoisseur here like
there's so many different factors right
because sometimes sometimes it's big but
like for some reason it's like hollow
inside right so you can take a good you
can shut it off sometimes it's just like
completely solid it's just like a solid
block of solid block of ice and there is
no like there is no biting down on that
unless it's at least a little bit melted
yeah at all and at that point it's going
to take at least like one or two minutes
irregardless of the size which is
like the grinding technique
yeah it's over for my teeth but i'm like
i take one bite and i'm like okay this
isn't a hollow one all right switch to
space to grinding technique
i remember it was quite a hefty boy it
was it was a weighty boy hence why again
i wanted to put it in my mouth
[Laughter]
it looks like i want all the trash they
said it's taken out of context it looked
too good not to like to allow it to go
away so i had of course yeah so for me
it's the opposite for me if it's like
perfectly the edges are like perfectly
rounded that's that's that's the that's
peak ice that's peak ice to put in your
mouth that is peak ice to put in your
mouth because it all you know you're one
of those rocks
with like the giant balls
no joke every time i get like
recommended a video of like one of the
waiters like shaving ice yeah it's what
it's like the most satisfying yeah in my
life whole yeah i need to say i don't
want to put it in my mouth um because i
don't want to die
oh yeah i yeah i've learned my lesson
with that it was also like clear ice
superior ice superiorized to like the
the [ __ ] frosted ice that you get
where it's like clear outside and
frosted in the middle that's that's
trashed here right now
this is just like level one bartending
right yeah
no i mean just like i think
to chew on it as well
yeah sorry i'm just this this is like my
[ __ ] five-year-old this is like now
this is like my favorite crayons taste
like level of conversation it's like i
like the the maroon one
i like cherry red because it's got the
word cherry do you prefer do you prefer
cubed ice or how do you feel about uh i
don't give a [ __ ]
no no no because because i know a lot of
people who [ __ ] hate crushed ice oh
yeah okay actually yeah i do hate crush
i really like crush i like crushed eyes
yeah why did you it's like a slushie
you get like okay so you everyone knows
my soda take right where i i like it
just the wrong one yeah i just i like it
where you know you take a little bit of
the fizz out and like to me like crushed
ice has more of a surface area to just
to just like to just like make soda like
the perfect the perfect texture and the
perfect flavor because if you drink it
without a straw
right yeah oh it's it's great because if
you drink it with without a straw then
you get a lot of crushed ice that you
can chew on it
it's perfect you get the best of both
worlds
it's just like this is like you're like
yeah i don't mind they bring extra extra
colors in the crown packaging
to eat yeah yeah this is i i don't i
don't want to
taste the ice [ __ ] slush in my mouth
i want to taste the drink being cold
this is why when we go to denny's in
japan i hate their [ __ ] ice machines
the ice is always the shitty the
shittiest like shaved ice yeah and you
drink it and you just get a mouthful of
shaved ice and you got to do that
technique where you're like
putting it in my mouth
[Laughter]
i like it when it's like at the bottom
of the glass and then you do this and
then just oh my god
it's a lot it's the last little bit
where you get the flavor because it's
basically just shaved ice it doesn't
have a little bit more at the bottom it
stays at the top
i mean uh i mean you gotta like drink it
you know you go i mean it depends
because have you you've hung out with me
so you've you've seen how much you've
done
you've seen how much shaved ice i put
into there minimum yeah the minimum
amount of shaved ice i put into a cup if
i have the choice is half the cup yeah
that's the minimum for me this is why
when gang goes to the movie theater he's
like wow look how much value i'm getting
i get i've drank four drinks today it's
like no god you've drank something this
is filled with advice this man buys
chips and goes
to me like to me the saddest sight i've
i've ever seen in my life right is when
you go to like a shaved ice machine and
people put like a bit in like like like
a tiny bit like five percent of the
[ __ ] cup i do like one percent right
and then most of the time
and then you and then you fill up with
the soda right i'd rather people put no
in because you fill up this with a soda
the saddest [ __ ] sight it's just
seeing like one or two bits of ice just
like floating around in the soda like
that that's doing nothing it's literally
doing nothing why would you put ice in
if it's if that's all you're actually
gonna put in
i'm not living in a cab i've never given
a [ __ ] i've never been like seething
rage me like god damn it because you
can't even chew on the ice that's that's
why that's why it doesn't matter because
it's gonna probably get a [ __ ] melt
i'm gonna predict god's next take he
thinks that soup should be exclusively
eaten with straws
right
i don't i don't i mean
yeah it's just a drink isn't it yeah
he's like oh this is a drink soup is a
drink it's quicker it's less messy
and curry is a drink
i want clown taking you to come out with
next guys
i'm i'm collecting them right now just
just give me more food the infinity
stones of [ __ ] taste
christ [ __ ] taste can be whatever i want
them to be